talk about the three characters and they
all started in the same place and they
all take different paths to kind of
remain strong within themselves and you
talk about how you see that happening in
life yourself yeah so well I mean I can
definitely relate to these characters
because uh similar things happen to me I
think with with I can totally relate
with every single one of them like say
Marcus for instance I didn't you know go
through the UH necessarily the same
level of violence that he did but uh I
went through the same choice I was the
guy hanging out on the corner drinking
beers with my friends and things like
that and one day that wasn't enough me
and I wanted to go to college and I
remember the day I told my friends I
wanted to go to college is it will you
want to go to college and it was a and I
chose to go anyway regardless of the
peer pressure oh here's the college guy
in other night and you know every time
you call ICU now you say in a new word
that I don't know and it was all kinds
of peer pressure like that but you know
I think in life anytime you're doing
something like that you follow your
heart and you stay true to you and as
long as you believe in what you're doing
you just do it so I but at the same time
I went to college and even though I love
the people that I was with and I love
the neighborhood and everything like
that it's there's a separation that
occurs when you do something like that
and I found out later on that it wasn't
them that changed it was me that changed
and because you know I went to college
and that makes a change in a person and
for me it was for the good you know but
at the same time I had you know people
in a neighborhood present you get
resentment now because you laughed at
all now you think you're better than I
am and to me that kind of represents
Marcus the leaving of the neighborhood
you know and then coming back later on
but then people misinterpreting him as
an individual because he left you know
and said oh you left so you think you're
better than us it was like no I left
because I was trying to find myself and
that's kind of where Marcus is and he
ends up having a resentment towards guys
in the neighborhood because they don't
understand him now and even though he
still feels a part of that neighborhood
so that's one of the things with the
characters that really resonated with me
it's interesting and it is it almost
like that those characters are not sure
where they really fit in because they're
kind of caught where they did kind of
leave that that situation but then it's
hard maybe going to that new world
because those people didn't have to deal
with some of the things that they had to
deal with they don't quite understand
you you you captured detective Morgan
that's detective Morgan because he was a
vice cop and he worked undercover for a
long time at gang detail and things like
that and he at the point in the film
he's making a transition from that to
missing children's and he got
transferred there because he was because
he has resentment towards gangbangers he
was taking out his anger on him so he
would do stuff at night pull over a guy
and beat him up in the end design ends
up island give away the full story but
he ends up getting in the doghouse and
now he has to get transferred to the
missing children department and he's
going through a transition there where
he doesn't feel like he fits in after
all of the years of being a cop now he
doesn't fit in and what he's doing and
he's also in the crossroad so it's
basically like these three guys who are
in the crossroads they've got baggage
that they have to put down in order to
move forward in their lives
you